girl you are making 90-day fiance
history right what kind of pressures
come with being a part of the first
same-sex couple for a 90-day fiance I
feel like there's a lot of pressure you
know you don't want to let down anybody
you don't want to let down the LGBT
community and a part of me wants to be
like great representation for this
community but also I think we all just
need to realize we're just like any
other couple we're gonna have just you
know similar problems to all the other
couples on the show and I hope that
people you know come into this with an
open mind and you know give us a chance
to share our story and see that there
are some similarities but also maybe
some differences too that we'll have to
deal with as far as our relationship but
I'm super excited it's crazy this feels
so surreal yeah this is a huge moment
coming out for me because I've you know
just recently come out and you came out
on the show yep
it was it was very scary and it was kind
of like ripping off a band-aid that's
been there for a very long time and I'm
always crazy and doing wild spontaneous
things I do put a lot of my life out
there online but this was a part of me
that I've kept kind of private and so
now I'm just putting it all out there
erica is worth this big risk because we
have an intense connection that I've
never felt with anybody before do you
feel like people will be skeptical of
you unveiling the fact that you are
bisexual on a national television show I
think people will definitely be
skeptical obviously you know I'm a
social-media influencer I'm a youtuber
so people already just question okay
well why is this girl doing this is it
you know all just for attention or
whatever but honestly like this is this
is how I've always been I've always
aired my life out on YouTube I'm a
storyteller and I like being open and
honest and vulnerable because I want to
make other people feel less alone and
I want other people to feel understood
because for such a long time I felt
really misunderstood like I really felt
that nobody knew really who I was or
what I was going through and you know
there's a lot of stigma in the LGBT
community but there's also a lot of
stigma for bisexuals for a lot of people
it's not taken seriously even within the
LGBT community it's like oh you know
like why can't you just choose why don't
you just decide in two men are you into
women and you know there will be lots of
issues tackled this season so everyone
will have to stay tuned and see what
exactly happens but I'm really proud and
happy that we are gonna be the first
couple that is going to be kind of
unveiling all these issues and showing
the world what it's really like
how does it feel watching it back now
it's weird because sometimes you forget
things that you said or things that you
did so watching it again like oh no why
did I say that because usually in real
life any arguments you have they're left
in the past but now they rear their ugly
head when you participate in you know a
dating reality show so I can only
imagine they do play out in their
authenticity and how they played out in
their original form for the most part
right yeah
it's going to be so weird watching
myself and watching my family you know
hopefully I didn't say any crazy stuff
but I think it'll be good it'll be like
holding a mirror up to myself you know
and just seeing okay well maybe I can
learn from myself too so I really want
to tell my family tonight about my
bisexuality but my mom's opinion matters
a lot to me I don't want her to be upset
by the news
why did you decide to share your story
on TV especially the aspect of you
coming out officially I felt like this
was a way of doing it
that was so gutsy and just so crazy that
there'd be no possible way for me to go
back because I had like one foot out the
closet and one foot in the closet for so
many years I almost came out so many
times and this was just like I'm just
gonna go all-in I'm literally just going
to dive in headfirst into the deep end
of the pool
no going back now everyone's going to
know and it's like officially starting a
new chapter of my life yeah when as I
imagine for most people that are coming
out it's especially difficult to tell
your family we see that play out for you
so now that we're seeing the aftermath
of what's been filmed how was your
family feeling well you guys are gonna
have to see on the season that's
definitely a really major part of my
story and I think the big takeaway from
it is that no one's coming out journey
is ever going to be the same it's never
going to be cut and dry and as simple as
just telling your parents shaking their
hands and leaving you know and it's a
lot to process and sometimes it may take
multiple tries and sometimes you might
have doubts about doing it but I hope
that by watching me and Erica people see
that you know hey you can do this and if
you're not ready and that's okay you can
take your time you know you just have to
do what you feel comfortable with and
what's right for you there is no right
time to come out it's when you just
decide that it's ready were you a fan of
the show before you ended up
participating in the show I along with
many people I'm a fan of the show I love
it I think it's hilarious
raw real ridiculous I like that you know
unlike some reality shows that portray
people so perfectly like I'm once
you know beautiful and perfect and
without flaws and great this really
shows like all types of people you know
like everyday real-life people and and
just really odd situations that you
really wouldn't be able to get on any
other type of show and also my parents
they were a green card marriage
so I feel like I kind of relate to a lot
of the couples on the show through
backstage okay have you often found
yourself seeking relationships with
folks that are outside of the US pretty
much everybody I've dated
is a something to you I think so what
does it say that I just love a challenge
a challenge do you also love or do you
feel like commitment is a challenge for
you because I would say it's not
obviously your conventional traditional
way to have a relationship with someone
that lives so many thousands of miles
from you that you can't see them daily
weekly maybe even monthly yeah I guess I
just love dating people who are very
different from me like culturally and
just a different background I don't know
what it is I just I like people who are
exotic
we live in New York City there's Little
Italy there's Chinese there's like all
these different places in New York so
you like a little distance between there
- yeah well the distance is hard it's
definitely something that I don't think
I would want to do long term with
somebody so you know we'll just have to
wait and see but I have dated my fair
share of people from different countries
different religions different
backgrounds different genders and you
know that's just used and I'm Aussies
though they are okay what surprised you
most about the journey let's see what
just what surprised me the most I guess
what surprised me the most was how much
I'm actually really capable of doing
like I'm able to actually withstand a
30-plus hour flight that's amazing I'm
very proud of myself
some of the crazy things that we did in
Australia I'm literally shaking just
looking back on it like wow I'm alive
you were very adventurous in Australia
the most I've ever been in my entire
life do you have a favorite couple from
the franchise Darcy of course she's a
legend she is alleged in every game in
here today yeah yeah she is legendary
yeah well mentioning Darcy if things
don't pan out with you and Erica would
you be willing to take on this challenge
again and this with dark areas I guess
you could take it on with Darcy but you
never know
I never know but I guess in this setting
of 90 day fiancé
would you do that again because she's
clearly this ain't her first rodeo with
the show right right no I don't know
what her orientation is mm-hmm
maybe if things don't work out and the
future I'm just kidding yeah honestly I
don't know I guess I just have to wait
and see how everything pans out
this was really scary for me even though
I am so public online this is a whole
new realm for me it is the most
vulnerable I've ever been in front of an
audience so
[Music]